Speaker 1: Speaker 1: So Trump, former Secretary
of Defense Mark Esper writes in his book and goes
on 60 Minutes and says Trump wanted to bomb
Mexico. And here's how I talked him out of
it. And there's other witnesses that heard that as
well. Well, certainly Trump is going to deny it,
right? Trump does not deny it, which means he did
it. Donald Trump, in response to Mark Esper's book
and the 60 Minutes interview, put out a sort of
Q&A, a Q&A, and we're going to look at it right
now. And it is one of the most deranged documents
I've maybe ever seen from a president. It's a Q&A.
First question During a June one, 2020 meeting
at the White House, the Cabinet was debating
what to do about protests and civil unrest. Mark
Esper says President Trump wanted to shoot some
of the protesters in the legs. A lot of foul
language was used and accused President Trump
of calling members of the Cabinet f ing losers.
Trump Trump's response This is a complete lie
and ten witnesses can back it up. Well, who
are they? And can we can we talk to them?
Mark Esper was weak and totally ineffective, and
because of it, I had to run the military. I took
out ISIS, Kassam, Soleimani, al-Baghdadi, rebuilt
the military with 2.5 trillion, created space
force and so much more. Mark Esper was a stiff who
was so desperate not to lose his job. He would do
anything I wanted. That's why I called him. Yes,
super. He was a lightweight and figurehead. And I
realized that early on he was recommended to me by
some very weak rhinos. And that is what he turned
out to be. Now. This is a typical Trump lie.
Like I don't believe him as far as I can throw
him. But more importantly, Trump keeps having to
go out and say, Well, Bolton was a lightweight.
Esper was a lightweight. Tillerson was right.
You know, all these people Trump ran on,
I'm going to hire the best people and I'm the best
at picking folks. And yet he was snowed by rhinos
and hired all the wrong people. That's weird. Next
question to Trump. President Trump wanted to send
10,000 active duty troops into DC after St John's
church was set on fire. Trump's response? Ron
I wanted to send at least 10,000 troops
for January 6th because I knew people
were coming to protest the corrupt presidential
election. Pelosi and the DC mayor turned me down.
60 Minutes should ask them why they
chose not to have proper security.
And remember, as we know on that day, all sorts of
people, including Ivanka, were saying he's got to
bring in the National Guard and he didn't do that
for hours. Second to a couple last questions here.
Later in a meeting at the White House, President
Trump contended that his secretary of defense
had taken away his authority on the Insurrection
Act and didn't believe he could invoke it
any more. This is fake news. The fact is, I
didn't need to invoke the act and never did.
And lastly, we can skip to the last question. On
a couple of occasions, President Trump suggested
to Esper they, quote, attack the drug cartels
with missiles, meaning bomb Mexico. Trump's
response is no comment. No comment. That means
he did it. That means he did it. And, you know.
Speaker 2: We're.
Speaker 1: With almost beyond words.
We are dealing with a complete and total lunatic.
This guy would be in a in a in a business where
national security isn't at stake, you
know, running a construction company,
running a restaurant, running an accounting
firm anywhere. People would say this person
is impossible to deal with. He's completely
disconnected from reality. He is making it
impossible for anybody to do their jobs.
And it's bad. And that person has been put
in charge or was put in charge of running
the entire country, a complete and total
dangerous, narcissistic lunatic. And we
continue to learn more every single week.
One other thing that I want to go back to here.
If everybody that he hired ended up being they
were losers. They were idiots. They're lying.
They're rhino traders. You know, Pence did the
wrong stuff. He didn't overturn the election. And
William Barr wasn't willing to take legal action.
Trump wanted him to take on the election, and
Esper was just a yes man. And then, you know, Mark
Milley was a woke general and Bolton is a loser
on and on and on. What does it say about Trump's
judgment that he continually appointed these
so-called losers to the highest office in the
land to do some of the most important functions
that a president needs to appoint people to do?
It doesn't speak particularly well to I will work
with only the best people. It is bonkers. It is
absolutely bonkers. We're going to take a quick
break and be back right after this. Stay with us